[Musik]
ich halte sie bekommt meine damen und
herren dazu führte nach acht meine
großartigen und sehr debattierfreude
gäste heute abend sind die professoren
und publizistin oracle guru ihr herz
gehört der meinungsvielfalt und europa
über die zukunft von europa und wie
diese aussehen könnte möchte sie heute
abend entsprechend spd-politiker und
bundestagsabgeordnete stegner ist
überzeugt olaf scholz ist ein frieden
ist ganz leicht bin sehr gespannt
rechtsanwältin jessica heimat
beschäftigt die blind bankrotterklärung
des bundesverfassungsgerichts wer
schützt die bürger vor den übergriffen
statt last but not least heiner bremer
sie werden ihn kennen er ist einer der
profiliertesten journalisten unseres
landes unter anderem entwickelte und
moderierte er die nachrichtensendung rtl
nachtjournal schön dass sie alle da sind
mein name ist der schicke und ich freue
mich die gastgeberin heute abend sein zu
dürfen meint thema kommt heute aus der
show aber auch nicht ganz es ist johnny
depp hat gegen alba haut vor gericht
gewonnen ein us gericht hat die
missbrauchs vorwürfe von amber heard
gegenüber johnny depp abgeschmettert es
ist ein wichtiges urteil das zeigt ja
auch frauen können täter sein können
männer freuen wenn ihren ruf in den
dreck ziehen und sind dem itil
vernichten in den letzten jahren seit
dem aufkommen der mito bewegung im jahr
2016 wurden männer vermehrt öffentlich
hingerichtet viele zu recht schweine wie
habel einzeln oder auch jeffrey epstein
verurteilt von gerichten doch es gibt
auch fälle den aussage gegen aussage
steht und die beweislage mehr als dünn
ist der comedian luke mockridge ist so
ein fall bei ihn seine ex freundin im
juni wegen versuchter vergewaltigung
angezeigt hatte folgte eine
gesellschaftliche hinrichtung dabei
wurde das verfahren gegen ihn
eingestellt
ich möchte heute mit der runde darüber
debattieren wie es eigentlich ist ob
nicht mehr länger in deutschland die
unschuldsvermutung gilt und was man
eigentlich dagegen tun kann wenn jemand
von der gesellschaft vorverurteilt wird
mein fazit ist mentor dieses urteil ein
wichtiger schritt für die
gleichberechtigung
ja also sie sprechen dann glaube ich
ganz wichtige dinge an allerdings würde
ich diesen fall gar nicht so sehr als
sozusagen für eine seite sehen sondern
in den situationen ist es immer so dass
es menschliche schicksale sind und es
steht ganz also fast immer aussage gegen
aussage und da ist es natürlich ganz
wichtig unvoreingenommen den gegenüber
zu stehen und das ist gerade wenn es um
sexualdelikt oder häusliche gewalt geht
häufig nicht der fall so dass wir
durchaus eine vorverurteilende
presseberichterstattung zum einen haben
aber zum anderen jetzt nur weil diese
entscheidung so gefallen ist heißt das
auch noch nicht dass die entscheidung
richtig war deswegen ich sehe das auch
bei twitter dass es teilweise gefeiert
wird ja hier sieg auf der richtigen
seite wir wissen uns einfach nicht also
wir kennen den prozess leider besser als
wir ihn kennen sollte das muss man dazu
sagen ich denke dieses thema ist
allerdings nicht nur ein juristisches
thema nämlich dass es eben auf falsche
beschuldigungen gibt es schadet den die
tatsächlich opfer von gewalt werden er
schadet aber auch es schreckt natürlich
dann ab denn opfer von gewalt überlegen
sich dreimal ob sie jetzt hier diesen
ganzen prozess durchmachen ich weiß was
als strafverteidigerin sehr gut ich
würde da auch manchmal die nebenklage
und es kann natürlich sein im zweifel
für den angeklagten das auch jemand der
tatsächlich schuldig war freigesprochen
wird das heißt aber noch lange nicht
dass die beschuldigung nicht gestimmt
hat denn natürlich sind die
anforderungen auch sehr hoch was ich
aber viel problematischer finde ist dass
dieser prozess ich meine haben sich zwei
menschen die wollten sich vernichten
also anders kann man es nicht mehr sagen
eine solche plattform bekommen haben ein
solches interesse von der gesamten
weltbevölkerung schon fast dass ich
sagen muss so kann rechtsstaat nicht
funktionieren und man sollte auch als
journalist journalistin in solchen
stellen eher ein bisschen zurückhaltung
üben um soeben rechtsstaatlichen prozess
auch nicht zu gefährden am ende das
würde das bei uns auch so nicht geben da
sehr amerikanisch diese totale
veröffentlichung öffentlichmachung
dieser ganzen vorgänge im deutschen
strafgerichten würde man da schon sehr
aufpassen dass das ein bisschen
diskreter gemacht werde ich bin
ich will nur das letzte sagen dazu noch
oder 1 punkt sagen es ist eigentlich mit
das heikle thema sexualdelikt
vergewaltigung weil du fast immer nicht
ganz sicher wisst wem du eigentlich
glauben kannst ich hab das ja selbst mal
erlebt als referendar war ja auch mal
oder bin ja eigentlich gelernter jurist
aber sie hat sich jahrzehnte her in
einer strafkammer bei solchen prozessen
es ist extrem schwer herausfinden wer
schwindelt dich jetzt an und wer sagt
die wahrheit
es gibt leichtere sachen zu beurteilen
und als strafrichter darf ich nur eine
empfehlung dazu machen was mir gerade
einfällt karen will ist eine
französische schriftstellerin eine sehr
gute zeitgenössische schriftstellerin
und die hat gerade einen großartigen
roman gehabt hause herausgebracht die
heiße shows und menschliche dinge und da
ist genau das der sachverhalt es gibt
eine vorverurteilung twitter und so
weiter dass er der täter ist also der
junge aus gutem französischen elternhaus
vergewaltigt die orthodoxe jüdin ja das
ist so der plot ja und am ende kommt zum
gerichtsverfahren und das gericht stellt
fest dass das was sozusagen juristisch
der akt war keine vergewaltigung ist und
dass die sozusagen twitter und so
vorverurteilt haben und das ist wirklich
im blick nicht guter roman und ich hoffe
dass das jetzt wird gestrichen die
touristischen teil funktioniert
wahrscheinlich bei uns auch noch ganz
gut aber es gibt eben zwei seiten die
probleme müssen die eine ist es gibt
eine art von vorwürfen die sie
buchstäblich ruinieren ja und ja ansehen
wenn sie dürfen nicht personen sind egal
ob sie stimmen oder nicht dazu gehören
solche sachen wie kinderpornografie oder
so was wir jetzt an der solchen fertig
wird und zweitens gilt aber halt leider
auch weil ich so schwer ist zu beweisen
es gab bei vielen frauen so dass sie
sich schon überhaupt anzeige zu
erstatten sie werden teilweise sogar
abgehalten davon ich habe ein interview
mit dem richter gelesen hat oder der
würde sagen einfach das nicht empfehlen
da anzeige zu erstatten weil am ende
werden wir das alles durchgeknetet
halböffentlich und es kommt nichts dabei
raus was wahnsinnig schwer ist es
nachzuweisen und davon gibt es die
beiden seiten da gibt es diejenigen die
gewalt allein das wird nicht bestraft
das sind schlecht dran und die die
falsch beschuldigt werden immer sicher
weniger aber kommt halt auch vor wenn du
vor auf entsprechende öffentlich
personen sind sie erledigt aldi hat
generelle kachelmann zum beispiel türk
zum beispiel die waren danach ja
wirklich
also ich stehe jetzt bestimmt nicht
glaube ich dass man denkt er herr
kachelmann und ich werden freunde wenn
man sich unsere twitter aufruf wieder
anschaut aber mit rückblicken leid was
mit dem mann passiert ist und ich frag
mich schon ob so ein prozess überhaupt
hilft dass die gesellschaft so stark
vorverurteilt also im fall von luke
mockridge das war damals beim
comedypreis das war furchtbar für mich
mit anzusehen obwohl ich den mann nicht
mal scanner wie er dort verurteilt wurde
ohne dass überhaupt schon was vor
gericht vorstand und es war da ja schon
eigentlich noch aussage gegen aussage
und da frage ich mich schon mit zwei
juristen ja ja auch ob man gar nicht was
dagegen tun kann dann sind wir an einem
ganz wunden punkt nämlich an eigentlich
eine angebrachten selbst kritik der
medien die vorverurteilung finden doch
fast immer in den medien statt weil
natürlich muss man so einen fall
aufgreifen und dann spitzt man die fälle
auch zu da hat das gericht überhaupt
noch gar kein ton gesagt und trotzdem
kommt er der mann oder die frau wenn du
ihn das sehr geschickt läuft dann
gemacht wird kommt aus diesem ding nie
mehr raus die kann auch freigesprochen
werden es ist völlig wurscht ist bleibt
was hängen das ist ja auch die methode
irgendwas bleibt schon hängen das macht
man ja auch wenn man skandale hoch
blinkt ein hoch bringt in der politik
ohne dass man
das wirklich ganz hart belegen kann aber
erst mal los mannschaftlich optimismus
zum teil in einer irgendeiner sache
beschuldigt wird dann sagen wir wie den
kenne ich gar nicht also das dann als
ist dass sich absetzungen jemand der
unter druck das finde ich eine person
der ganzen haft er war nicht im
gegenteil ich ein impuls für die tanks
in anständiger menschen wird zunehmen
falls man nicht einen schlechten
charakter und ich bin mit dem gar nicht
gesehen wenn wir was dabei rauskommt das
ist so ein stück nicht nur jetzt bei
straftaten sondern generell
gesellschaftlicher operation nicht
sozial und umweltpolitik am morgen hat
ist natürlich auch so wenn jemand dann
verurteilt wird und gerichte das
entscheiden dann muss das natürlich auch
akzeptiert werden also dieses herum
barmen bei dem uli hoeneß zum beispiel
als der damals vorteil wegen
steuerhinterziehung also diese tränen
geschichten sozusagen dafür jeder
präsident des vereins werden wenn ich 30
millionen gezogen habe das wünsche ich
will man bei jugendlichen straftätern
dass es sowas gibt ihn also gibt auch
die andere seite aber es war
selbstständig und wo häufig noch
hinweisen möchte ist was
die intervention sozusagen die
journalistische die kann meines
erachtens auch entscheidungen
beeinflussen also wenn jetzt jemand der
bekannt ist dem vorwurf der
kinderpornografie was eben besonders
stark verurteilt wird auch also
gesellschaftlich zu recht aber
gleichwohl muss man natürlich den den
den maßstab waren und da ist es schon
meine feste überzeugung dass derjenige
dann direkt mann aus schlag bekommt oder
zum teil es ist ein anderes beispiel die
die casa verde ganz lange jahrzehnte
waren das fahrlässige tötung dann hat
unter anderem die bild zeitung darüber
berta bezeichnet und so weiter ich will
nicht sagen dass das ihr zu sagen das
gericht insoweit beeinflusst hat zu
sagen okay das ist jetzt mord aber es
spielt mit rein denn wo kommt das denn
her plötzlich so ein wechsel und da ist
es eben ganz weil wir reden hier von
existenzen existenzen von menschen im
zweifel ich habe das auch schon
tatsächlich persönlich erlebt dass
jemand der beschuldigt worden ist auch
ja medial nicht bekannt eine bekannte
person medial da sehr verfolgt wurde
sage ich mal um das ganze endete sehr
sehr tragisch und diese verantwortung
haben journalisten und journalistinnen
schon das gericht anders das haben sie
ja zu recht gesagt amerika werden die
gerichtsprozesse was extreme haben wir
nicht die kamera ist aus sobald der
prozess beginnt und dann können die
journalistin drin sitzen und darüber
schreiben das ist schon auch deutlich
besser aber auch da kann man natürlich
so eine art hexenjagd veranstalten und
das sollten wir doch vermeiden zum
schutze der angeklagte zum schutze der
mutmaßlichen opfers problem ist nur dass
die medien natürlich ein größeres
interesse haben wenn es sich in
irgendeiner form unbekannte um nicht zu
sagen prominente
vermeintliche täter handelt wären sie um
nobody's die das brutalste machen was
geht wie jetzt im fall wermelskirchen
mit diesen kinderpornografischen
geschichten da gehst du auf den fall ein
soweit ich den jetzt verfolgt habe in
allen zeitungen sehr cool und sachlich
und unter zitierung der polizei und da
merkst du auch die betroffenheit das
selbst ermittler sagen so was ist uns
noch nie untergekommen aber der ton ist
sachlich weil der typ wäre erstmal
wissen sie nicht genau sie wissen zwar
wäre das ist aber das ist den man
sozusagen
er hat keine geschichte der ist nur
krank das ist auch schon unterschied und
wenn es natürlich im fall in amerika
sind nun wenn wir zwei ganz prominent
stürzt sich doch alles dran ist
wird man also was seinen skoda die
ganzen plagiats-affäre ja auch noch
einmal zugenommen haben sozusagen den
letzten jahren und vor allem immer in
wahlkämpfen ja wenn man dann auch
inzwischen das gefühl das ist dass
gerade dann rauskommt wenn jemand
abgeschossen werden soll und so weiter
und so fort also ich finde schon auch
jetzt in jüngerer zeit ja das sagen wir
mal corona stichwort ja wer was gesagt
hat wie auch immer dass das was man so
hexenjagd nennen könnte öffentliche
hexenjagd dass das auch im sinne einer
vorverurteilung allgemein also jetzt
jenseits auch diese sexualdelikte die
glaube ich noch mal ganz besonders sind
ganz spezifisch ganz besonders natürlich
auch in die intimsphäre eben eingreifen
aber dass allgemein die vorverurteilung
zugenommen hat also ich würde zum
beispiel aber das stichwort nennen
wikipedia ist ja so eine open source wo
eigentlich jeder über jeden alles
mögliche schreiben kann ja und bis man
das dann wieder raus bekommt wenn es
irgendwie nicht stimmt dann vergeht echt
mal zeit ja also das ist ja auch eine
vorverurteilung dass jeder überlebende
im raum und genau anschauen kann man nie
wieder genau machen
der ist dann da weil man sozusagen
einmal negativ gedeckt wurde und
um wegzugehen von der rechtlichen frage
wir lagen ja auch dazu
alles so zu skandalisieren dass die
ganze öffentlichkeit bestürzt ist also
tief kann sagen das ist ein fettnäpfchen
dem frau lambrich wieder getreten ist
mit diesem helikopter flog aber dass das
jetzt ein großer skandal ist obwohl es
rechtlich sogar erlaubt ist was er
gemacht hat das finde ich bei uns
überzogen thomas jander werden gemacht
dass
es umgekehrt sagen die großen skandale
wo wirklich steuergelder von monaten
wären ja also an die chancen und
versinken oder wirecard und was auch
nicht wirklich richtigen sachen ja nix
geschäfte und so weiter die keiner mehr
versteht dem handelsblatt gemacht werden
wo im prinzip republik vermögen muss man
sozusagen wirklich veruntreut in großem
stil da regt sich keiner drum auf aber
der lebenslauf von anna lena wurde
irgendwie so eine halbe universität
studiert wurde das war natürlich ein
großes kann nachher kommt hier das
glaube ich jetzt zugute weil die leute
sie unterschätzt haben es kann auch
anders umgehen bei dem guttenberg ist da
kann übers wasser gehen
aber im gegensatz zu
den plagiats geschichten habe ich immer
gesagt guttenberg war ein skandal dass
in echt weil er glaube ich nichts
eigenes geschrieben oder jedenfalls 80
prozent war
bei den anderen bin ich schon sehr
zurückhaltend also bei schavan bei
gefahr
mein gott ist das so schlimm aber irgend
sowas vergisst wenn der rest aber
vernünftig ist ist dass das was uns in
der gesellschaft ist die tendenz zu
vereinfachung glaube ich auch wirecard
und so weiter das ist super kompliziert
verstehen vielen ländern oder auch
dieser helikopter flug auch cookies
können das ist ja wohl nicht wahr sein
aber diese empörung skulptur wie ist
glaube ich das problem und die zerstört
wirklich jetzt gerade noch mal auf ihr
thema zurückzukommen die zerstört eben
ganze biografien und jetzt kommen wir
sogar auf ein ganz wichtiges thema was
wir auch nicht skandalisieren wollen
nämlich alle froh weil sie haben europa
mitgebracht das ist ja wirklich ein sehr
zentrales thema ja ich stelle das man
hier auf den tisch ja den stier mit der
frau obendrauf kennen alle nein scherz
beiseite wir hatten ja jetzt den meist
gar nicht so lange her und neunter
europatag was ist an diesem neunten mal
passiert an diesem 9 es passiert dass
die sogenannte zukunftskonferenz der
europäischen union zu ende gegangen ist
jetzt werden die meisten zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer davon leider nichts gehört
haben aber es war eine ganz große übung
dass die europäische union über ein jahr
lang bürgerinnen und bürger zur zukunft
europas befragt hatten das war super
moderiert also es war auch random
selection die worten ausgewählt also
wirklich zufallsauswahl von 18 bis 90
dass die leute diskutiert haben und in
verschiedenen bürgerforen in venedig in
dublin und so weiter haben die leute
diskutiert und jetzt ist der report
davon vorgebracht worden deswegen habe
ich jetzt europa mitgebracht weil wir
jetzt wissen was die bürger wollen und
das interessante daran ist die bürger
wollen eigentlich mehr als die politiker
dh die bürger wollen zum beispiel dass
die einstimmigkeit wegfällt die bürger
wollen ein soziales europa die bürger
wollen wahrscheinlich sogar das ist
jetzt der neue trend vertragsreform nach
artikel 48 das heißt sie wollen europa
auf dem weg zu einer europäischen
verfassung bringen das heißt wir haben
da auf einmal eine ganz große dynamik
wenn es darum geht wie gestalten wir
diesen zirkus lesen kontinent und ich
wollte dass kurz verknüpft mit dem thema
ukraine wir sind ja nun mal in einem
krieg wir sehen gerade dass es europa
schlecht geht wir sehen dass dieser
krieg massive auswirkungen hat also auf
deutschland zum beispiel auf das soziale
gefälle auf die inflation auf die
beziehen preise und so weiter wir sehen
das aber in allen ländern das heißt wir
müssen fürchten dass dieser krieg
natürlich eigentlich auch zu ja sagen
wir mal verwüstungen in sozialer und in
anderer hinsicht für und natürlich zu
andere also und ganz unabhängig von den
bildern aus butter und so hat natürlich
aber was ich sagen wollte ist dass wo
wir verknüpfen müssen sind eigentlich
und damit höre ich dann auch schon auf
die beiden großen ziele was europa sein
sollte wir wollten ja können wir uns
kurz erinnern 1992 politische union
helmut kohl mit der l'or ja dieses
projekt das eigentlich bis heute
gescheitert wir haben keine politische
union und die frage ist jetzt mit dieser
zukunftskonferenz kriegen wir das
projekt noch mal wieder und das zweite
große ding und das ist der ukraine
konflikt was wir wollten zumindest es
wollten in den letzten 30 jahren ist die
eurasische friedensordnung ist die
sicherheitsstruktur in europa ist die
rockhal in frieden und was wir jetzt
machen unter dem eindruck der natürlich
tragischen bilder dieses
kriegsgeschehens ist natürlich
eigentlich spalt mir diesen kontinent
wieder neu wir gehen sozusagen alle
zurück in die nato wir beerdigen die
europäische souveränität und die
europäische autonomie wir sagen zwar
dass der krieg wie zu mehr einheit führt
und es tut da irgendwo auch ein bisschen
im energiebereich aber nicht so richtig
viel was aber für mich entscheidend ist
wir spalten eigentlich europa jetzt vom
baltikum runter bis zum schwarzen see
und dahinter ist russland darauf von der
leyen gesagt wir müssen die industrielle
basis russlands abtragen ich glaube das
ist keine putin jeder herr putin wird
irgendwann gehen ich glaube das ist
keine basis für den europäischen
kontinent und deswegen bin ich hier um
zu diskutieren wann kommen wir in eine
diskussion und das aktuelle tragische
kriegsgeschehen in der ukraine zu
verbinden mit einer politischen
diskussion über den kontinent europa
wollen wir sein haben wir noch
ambitionen politische ambitionen
souveränität und diese ganzen dinge
und dann würde ich sagen die ukraine
muss befriedet werden und unter eine
europäische sicherheitsarchitektur
natürlich eine europäische zukunft
bekommen aber dieses abschneiden europas
sozusagen vom osten was jetzt passiert
kann für diesen kontinent nicht
zielführend sein da würde ich direkt die
frage an herrn stegner geben ob wir den
kontinent neu spalten die frage wo
gerade gesagt ich hoffe dass nicht ich
glaube das ist in der aktuellen
situation ist es schwer zu diskutieren
weil wir mitten im krieg sind mitten in
europa alles muss schon sehen und weil
wir natürlich jetzt nicht nur sicherheit
mit so haben wir unsere vorstellung
sicherheit gibt es in europa nur mit
russland im augenblick muss man auch
über sicherheit gegen lausanne drehen
sowie das geführt ist ich glaube aber
trotzdem hinter viel optimistischer als
sie das am ende europa ist der kleinste
aber der wohlhabendste von den
kontinenten und wenn wir mitspielen
wollen mit china mit indien mit
brasilien mit amerika dann wird sich
europa zusammentun müssen haben wir
keine chance als eine wirtschaftsunion
und keine chance als eine die sozusagen
nationalismus zurückfällt sondern haben
wir nur dann eine chance wenn wir mit
einer stimme sprechen das bedeutet aber
dass wir auf der einen seite gegenüber
den diktaturen klar auftreten das
geschieht auch aber das natürlich mit
eigenen reihen auch nicht das dulden
dass wir nicht dulden dürfen dass in
polen die unabhängige gerichtsbarkeit
abgeschafft wird das in ungarn die
presse weil das wir dem erdogan vor
reden halten wieder sein müssen aber
selber und haben bestimmte nicht heißt
die demokratien sind extrem gefordert
dass die werte für die wir stehen das
die auch gelebt werden ist die stadt
finden die jungen leute meine
erfahrungen die die spaltung ist nicht
mehr erlebt haben
mauer und stacheldraht und all diese
dinge die sind gewohnt zu heißen die wir
brauchen keine pässe die leben in
frieden mit ihren nachbarn die haben
nichts gegen ihre nachbarn trafen den
könnten mehr polnisch oder französisch
lernen da kann man noch dran arbeiten
aber im kern jedenfalls ist dieses
friedliche wohlhabende europa was wir
genossen haben über viele jahrzehnte das
muss verteidigt und ausgebaut werden
sonst werden wir unseren wohlstand
nämlich verlieren und das ist der punkt
an dem wir momentan ein bisschen unter
druck durch den krieg aber ich glaube
nicht dass es dauer verloren also ich
finde das hier ein tolles theorie
gebildet ich fürchte nur dass die zeit
für solche diskussion im augenblick
überhaupt nicht greife
dass sie auch in der öffentlichkeit
darüber nicht diskutieren können
jedenfalls nicht mit dem normalbürger
der hat ganz andere sorgen im augenblick
wie gefährdet es eigentlich der rest
europas durch diese russische aggression
führt er den imperialismus immer weiter
was tun wir und dann erleben wir ja
ohnehin eine andere bewegung das in
europa wir weit entfernt sind von
ursprünglichen ideen einer politischen
einheit wir sind ja dabei dass immer
mehr staaten in der gefahr sind wieder
zu nationalstaaten abzurutschen in stark
autoritäre züge damit meine ich jetzt
nicht ungarn und orban soll ich meine
frankreich meiner auch italien das ist
nicht
sicher dass da nicht herrn savigny oder
jedenfalls seine läger wieder an die
macht kommt in frankreich wissen wenn
ich was bei den parlaments- verhalten
was hier entweder gibt es dann rechts
rutscht oder vielleicht linksrutsch
beides nicht unbedingt demokratie
fördern oder so wie wir es verstehen und
in beiden lernen dann sind das
gleichzeitig europa skeptiker die einige
europa nicht wollen marine le pen
genauso wie männer auch schon in
frankreich und salvini und die
wie heißt noch die freunde von herrn
konnte ja genau die musik
bestellt die sind ja auch nicht
sonderlich europa orientiert also ich
wir haben so viel will ich sagen
hausaufgaben im augenblick zu leisten
dass glaube jede idee die völlig
berechtigt ist wie kann die zukunft
eines weiter geeinten europas eigentlich
aus in dem augenblick
nicht perfekt weil das andere viel
wichtiger die leute die frage ist sowas
ist so wichtiger ist ja immer so eine
wechselbewegung mehr was ich und marcel
ist sie haben ihre analyse ist ja
perfekt das heißt wir haben eine innere
zersetzung bewegung also die ganzen
populismus parteien und so weiter in
europa und diese versetzung bewegung
fängt an nachgerade gefährlich zu sein
ist völlig richtig dass wir nicht mehr
nur von polen oder nur von ungarn reden
sondern eben frankreich und so weiter
wir haben alle gezittert marie le pen
ich saß ja noch höher ja hab noch
vorgetragen marine le pen und so weiter
italien großes thema so die innere
zersetzung geht aber einher und das
wollte ich eben sagen mit einem
klammergriff was man früher eine
diskussion im amerika genannt hat ja
also nur mal ein beispiel wir haben
jetzt die die zuglinie von belgrad nach
budapest wird jetzt von china gebaut ja
und vielleicht baut ja china demnächst
auch die buslinie von budapest nach
stuttgart ja also auf der anderen seite
haben wir jetzt auch durch corona
natürlich im mittelstand wirklich
probleme in europa bekommen
digitalisierung ist amerika gaffer
amazon und so weiter das heißt wir sind
geo komisch und geostrategisch in so
einer art america klammergriff und mein
plädoyer ist und dann ist die frage wann
machen wir das sie haben natürlich
völlig recht wir sehen also abgelenkt
von allen wichtigen themen ja aber auf
der anderen seite dieser große wurf ich
habe noch viel sagte lohr gearbeitet
daher hat man noch von grand prix europa
vom höchsten europäischen projekten
geredet und deswegen würde ich hier
gerne sagen wir brauchen jetzt mal ein
großes europäisches projekt benehmen und
zehn jahre für den euro war auch zehn
jahre gebraucht aber wir sagen einfach
mal bis 2030 oder 32 erstens zweitens
drittens europäische
arbeitslosenversicherung europäisches
bürgerstadt abschaffung der
einstimmigkeit usw buch stadien war das
aus gucken was die bürger jetzt auf den
tisch gelegt haben und dann haben wir
ein klares ziel vor augen und dann
rocken wir die diskussion kommen sie
eigentlich bevor sie am 9 wenn sie so
etwas vortragen in ihrer fraktion was
sagt die sind spinnt ihr da martin
schulz nicht mehr da ist wir das spiel
gesicht aber wenn mal so ich bin nicht
so skeptisch dass die europäische idee
war eine antwort auf den zweiten
weltkrieg und das in europa ein gesicht
war das blutigste kontinent überhaupt
jetzt werden wir durch andere dinge am
mahnt wir sehen was in china passiert
wir ahnen dass das mit dem trump
vielleicht noch nicht ausgestanden ist
das ist ein großes problem ist unser
spitze der westlichen welt macht jemand
stand der demokratie auch nicht
akzeptiert das capitol stürmen lässt
wahl nicht akzeptiert das könnte wieder
kommen das heißt europa kennt glaube ich
dass wir unseren wohlstand verlieren
wenn wir uns nicht zusammenreißen wir
reißen uns aber durchaus zusammen wir
merken bei den dänen bei den finden bei
den schweden die jetzt aus anderen
gründen die kommen ja nicht nur zur nato
sondern sie kommen auch ein stück die
dänen haben immer gesagt wir machen das
mit dem euro nicht das heißt wir uns
weiterhin krone aber wir machen jeden
schritt mit das ist eine ungefährliche
form von nationalismus ist wunderbar
national psychologie funktioniert
bestens und alle sind zufrieden und
solche dinge kann man auch machen aber
sehr punktuell alles also das ist glaube
ich so das problem aber ich glaube der
gedanken ist schon da das wir ahnen wir
haben auch eine verpflichtung gegenüber
seinen kindern dass er so bleibt wie wir
das haben erleben dürfen also ist garant
gedankenlesen und gerade und deswegen
also ich fand es ganz interessant ihren
einwurf jetzt ist nicht die zeit dafür
ja gerade jetzt ist eigentlich die
breite gegangen solche leidenschaft den
armen und nicht welche noch partie
richtig und nicht nur so am rande weil
wir die meisten beim europatag waren wir
ja in bonn für die meisten ist so wie
fähnchen und luftballons also so gefühlt
ja das ist aber mehr also europa muss
tatsächlich ja auch hätten gehören damit
er nichts anfangen letzten wichtig
außerhalb nur eins gelernt man muss sich
trennen von intellektuell überzeugenden
konzeptionen die man auch in seinen
kreisen in seiner blase wie es heute so
schön heißt gut diskutieren kann ich
muss aber bei den dingen die menschen
mitnehmen das ist ja so ein punkt den
die politik immer weniger vergisst dass
man bei allen sachen die menschen
irgendwie mitnehmen aber dieses mal habe
ich ja wichtiger gekommen mit dem bürger
vorschläge 49 vorschlägen die 300.000
europäischen bürgerinnen entwickelt
haben das heißt das sind ja die menschen
die das gemacht haben jetzt schon
richtig aber das ist doch nicht erst
noch nicht mal die deutsche bevölkerung
jetzt fragen sie die mal ob in der
jetzigen zeit wir noch mehr europa
wollen würde die aufgabe eigenen staat
er hat glaube ich recht was die fragen
endlich vermutlich das in der situation
jetzt aber der krieg wird ja hoffentlich
nicht noch ganz lange dauern aber es
gibt bessere zeiten dafür aber natürlich
nicht wichtig man muss dann auch etwas
überzeugen und mit mit mit leidenschaft
kommen muss davon dass man muss immer
sehen war das ist für sichere hall und
das ist eine gute sache ist und nicht
mit diesen drogen darlegungen die eine
wunderbare politik sprechen uns mit den
tag über intellektualisierung das
verbindet ich will ich war doch gar
nicht drin und ich habe angst
ich finde das was sie haben macht der
gesine schwan auch die sagt wir müssen
das machen mit der umfunktionierung
unserer gesellschaft kommt erfährt sie
in die lausitz diskutiert mit bürgern
darüber die nehmen wir die mit dass die
nicht gegen die umwandlung
industriegesellschaft sensation eine
party zu verstehen was ich mir als
bürgerin wenn ich eine talkshow und da
sitzen leute und sagen mal wie die
bürger empfinden was die bürger denken
immer genau an
wie werden wir morgen mittag immer
überwies von zu sprechen wir sind alles
reden also über ein bodenständiges thema
und der urlaub voll
arbeitende bürger
kleiner spalt sie dürfen loslegen mit
ihrer these ja wir machen ja etwas was
sehr ungewöhnlich ist wir machen ein
sondervermögen 100 milliarden euro für
die bundeswehr und da könnte man auf die
idee kam sozialdemokraten 100 millionär
und es ja und dann eben nicht gekommen
dann ein linker der hier setzt das hat
auch noch richtig findet und er findet
das aus zwei gründen richtig finde es
ist richtig weil wenn man eine
parlamentsarmee haben die bundeswehr ist
das dann darf man die nicht runter
kommen lassen dann darf man nicht sagen
die amerikaner übernehmen acht jahre
nach dem krieg noch unsere verteidigung
wir haben schiffe die nicht mehr als
tauglichen flugzeuge die nicht fliegen
fahrzeuge die nicht fahren keine
nachtsichtgeräte sind wirklich ganz
bescheiden ausgestattet das muss man
ändern und zweitens
das sondervermögen stellt sicher dass
wir in der zeit wo wir das machen müssen
zueinander zur bündnisverteidigung wir
das nicht zu lasten des machen wofür wir
gewählt worden sind nämlich wir wollten
nicht cdu politik machen sondern wir
wollten klimaschutz machen wir wollten
in bildung investieren wir wollen
digitalisierung machen wir wollen den
sozialstaat gerechter machen und
kindergrundsicherung man solche dinge da
wir eine schuldenbremse haben geht das
aber nur mit dem sondervermögen das
heißt sondervermögen aber es geht eben
neben geschuldet die union etwas haben
das nicht mitmachen und entsprechenden
punkt ist jetzt dass alle verstehen es
geht nicht um aufrüstung sodass geht
darum die ausrüstung zu verbessern und
breit ist und von lamprecht das nämlich
dass man sagen von lamprecht wird ja
nicht kritisiert wegen ihrer
stöckelschuhe oder weil sie einen
osterurlaub machen sondern weil sie den
rüstungskonzernen die wäsche gehen wer
diesen in den himmel wir haben nämlich
geld hatten wir genug
beschaffungsskandale managementposten
teure gutachten und die würden am
liebsten einfluss auf ihrem hof vom ort
zu bestpreisen verkaufen aber so
funktioniert darf das nicht vollständig
gerissen zu haben zu entscheiden sondern
die politik das heißt da muss kräftig
dazwischen gefahren werden und wir
brauchen wir europäische zusammenarbeit
augen auf denn die nato gibt deutlich
mehr ausrüstung als etwas ein oder
andere aber jeder macht im grunde genau
was er will und die verdienen sich eine
goldene nase an den dingen und deswegen
heißt sondervermögen ein
sozialdemokratischer friedens kanzel
sorgt dafür dass wir äußere sicherheit
innere sicherheit und sozialer reformen
gemeinsam machen kann das kann man so
die quelle
ich wollte nur sagen also so ganz nah
wir haben in europa 28 mal mehr rüstung
ohne amerika als russland ja also es ist
nicht so als wir nackt da stimmt vor dem
sondervermögen ja das wollte ich nur
sagen das ist nicht so als hätten wir
gar nicht so lange her bremer in einer
sackgasse die bundeswehr war blank des
wer war eigentlich wie es erstmal ganz
früher war und der spiegel -herausgeber
auch noch in dem brennenden haus sind
bedingt abwehrbereit und wahrscheinlich
das wort bedingt schon gar nicht mehr
ganz zu treffen
also der sondervermögen finde ich völlig
in ordnung und es ist in der tat ein
weckruf gewesen
putin das hat er erreicht er hat ja alle
seine politischen vorstellungen
treten ja nicht ein hat ja wohl gedacht
dass alle welt schläft und sich nicht
wehrt und so lassen wir das mal was mich
bei der ganzen diskussion um
sondervermögen und friedens kanzlei
kriegen auch
stört ist eigentlich dass wir die
debatte viel zu politisch führen und zu
wenig wirklich politisch also erstens es
ist sicher richtig dass deutschland
nicht nur im rahmen der nato oder der eu
sondern grundsätzlich auch wegen der
vergangenheit aber die es gegenüber der
ukraine wie in der sowjetunion damals ja
gleich verheerend schon aufgerufen ist
einem land zu helfen das überfallen
worden ist ohne dass es dafür
irgendeinen anlass gab die frage ist
auch nicht machen wir das auch mit
militärhilfe denn gegen ein aggressor
kannst du dich nur mit militärischen
mitteln wehren und nicht mehr nur mit
schönen reden für mich ist der wunde
punkt in der ganzen diskussion dass
weder die regierung noch die opposition
noch die medien den mut haben zu fragen
wohin das eigentlich für welchen zweck
verbinden wir mit welchen
waffenlieferungen wie weit können wir
mitgehen wenn die ukraine
natürlich das letzte und einzige recht
hat zu entscheiden jetzt verhandelte ich
oder die verhandelnden nicht wir können
der ukraine nicht diktieren welche
zumutungen bedingungen
auflagen zu akzeptieren hat aber wir
können schon und da bin ich anderer
meinung als der kanzler gestern
zumindest im kopf haben wo wir sagen
freunde macht wenn ihr das wollt aber
nicht mehr mit uns auch nicht mehr mit
unserer hilfe
da sind wir viel freier als die
amerikaner wahrscheinlich wollen wir
kein verärgern und der botschafter wenig
hat erreicht dass wir den mund nicht
mehr auf kriegen die amerikaner seien
klar was sie wollen sie sagen die
ukraine darf nicht verlieren und
russland muss so geschwächt werden dass
ein solcher überfall so schnell nicht
wieder passieren kann sie sind aber sehr
darauf bedacht dass keine waffen
geliefert werden die sie auch nur
indirekt als kriegspartei ausweisen
nehmen wir das jüngste beispiel die
mehrfach raketenwerfer hochmodern hat
offenbar nicht haben wenn man sie
richtig munitioniert auch eine
reichweite von 100 bis 200 kilometern
die auflage ist die kriegen nur munition
die maximal 70 kilometer weit geht das
heißt nur für die abwehr im donbass
benutzt werden kann nicht für
irgendwelche ja sagen wir mal läufer die
dann auf russischem gebiet ein schlagen
und das ist für mich schon wichtig wir
wissen doch alles am ende
entscheidend waffen nicht die kriege
sondern irgendwann ist ein punkt wo du
verhandeln muss meint ja moment wir
diskutieren das aber nicht weil wir dann
immer sagen wir können der ukraine
nichts vorschreiben wir können auch mal
darüber diskutieren gerade vorgeworfen
dass er sagt zu recht wie ich über uns
finden wir reden über ökonomische
finanzieller humanitäre politische
diplomatische auch über militärische
aber die die militärische hilfe ist wir
versuchen der ukraine sich zu
verteidigen wir schließen strikt aus
dass deutschland den krieg hineingezogen
was die nato involviert wird wir wollen
dass der krieg nicht eskaliert er redet
von seinem amtseid schaden vom deutschen
volk abzuwenden das heißt übersetzt ja
was mit der nasa auch sagen auf der
straße auch sagen bitte keinen krieg wir
wollen die nicht haben als die ukraine
gesagt hat macht eine flugverbotszone
über der ukraine haben wir auch klipp
und klar nein dazu gesagt weil wir
wussten dass heißt als dass man es ist
alles bekannt es ist aber auch mal keine
einer die linie die außenministerin hat
jetzt gesagt die ukraine muss gewinnen
ich frage mich was ist dann ja aber das
ist ja genau das problem also ich mag
thematisieren und denke auch dass wir
haben ja inzwischen auch ich glaube
tatsächlich erst mal dass sich die
diskussion inzwischen ein bisschen
gedreht hat ja in der new york times im
wall street journal dass nämlich genau
auch vor allen dingen amerikanische
strategen moosheimer wissen ja wie auch
immer inzwischen sagen moment mal was
heißt dann gewinn du willst auch
deutsche generäle herr kujat einige die
artikel haben sagen es ist nicht auf dem
schlachtfeld zu entscheiden wir müssen
genau wir müssen über verhandlungen
nachdenken über eine friedensordnung
oder garantien wir müssen das problem
ist nicht die position so das problem
ist in die etiketten die verteilt werden
richtig falsch gemacht und bösen putin
verstehe oder kriegshetzer und darum
geht es natürlich nicht so ich glaube
ich persönlich finde krieg furchtbar das
ist das schönste was passiert wir haben
menschen umgebracht frauen vergewaltigt
leute flüchten zerstörung jeden tag
stellungskrieg hört sich harmlos an und
das heißt zerstörung viele viele tage
und deswegen heißt es nicht so zufrieden
um jeden preis aber das heißt schon das
feuerpause humanitäre hilfe warten wie
jo entweder haben müssen und wir helfen
zur verteilung deswegen ist der sachse
oder schaltet man nicht übrigens auch
die ukraine darf den krieg nicht
verlieren dass sie die perspektive des
angegriffenen muss danach den krieg
krieg nicht gewinnen dass die
perspektive angaben ist die anderen
formulierung finde ich schwierig weil
die kriegsziele definieren die womöglich
ganz anderer art sind und das kann man
nicht wollen das kann man auch nicht
richtig finden und am ende übrigens
verdruss land auch bleiben russland
vielleicht problem und wir haben es auch
mit anderen diktaturen zu tun herr
stegner das ist alles natur ein ansatz
mein ansatz ist dass diese debatte bei
uns nicht wirklich ehrlich geführt
in einer ganz afrika brechung direkt
zurück und dann geht es direkt weiter
mit dem ansatz von herrn bremer
also da kann ich dann ein lauter krach
und nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei 14 85 köpfen fünf meinungen
jeder von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht
was ihn bewegt tage alt freut oder
schockiert
so nicht privat jet buschi herr jörges
wetten das auge ist aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen wir einfach nur freiheit
diese grün-roten der damen führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russland
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur derart zu überlassen lasst den
leuten noch man den spaß wir sehen da
etwas was eigentlich fatale ist in der
politik bei den journalisten deren job
ist es doch gerade abweichende meinungen
zu fügen und sie sollen den doch auch
richtig gut
vielleicht einmal kurz einsatz werden
wir ganz nennen doch das sind übliche
andrack träger
ausdrücken ich hatte meinen beifall um
eine sache immer bekommen er kümmert
sich darum niemand
muss der ganz kleinen auch darüber
sprechen das ist einfach nicht der könig
richtig wohl ist die aufgabe von
journalismus einfach
die verlautbarung der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und ich über die wir
direkt geschwind an heiner bremer wir
sind ja bei der diskussion wie mir fehlt
nämlich dass wir zwar mit hohen
militärischen sachverstand inzwischen so
wie wir auch eine zeitlang ja alle
virologen war
überwachen diskutieren wie gut wie
beweglich wie schnell wie treffsicher
sie sind also immer irgendwie polizist
es bleiben aber die frage der
politischen verantwortung dabei wie weit
können wir mitgehen wie weit geht eine
unterstützung für einen überfall eines
land wie die ukraine wo sind da die
grenzen oder würden wir auch mitgehen
wenn die ukraine sagt jetzt sind wir so
stark jetzt zeigen wir es den russen mal
und wir greifen auch russisches
territorium an die amerikaner wollen das
offenkundig nicht bei uns wird die
diskussion nicht geführt beim kanzler
glaube ich schon dass das was niemals
zögern und zaudern immer vorgebracht man
es genau diese nachdenklichkeit und
besonnenheit ist verdammt noch mal wie
weit kann ich gehen ohne dass die
risiken nicht zu groß werden wie
reagiert der mensch im kreml den ja
keiner mehr für berechenbar wirklich
hält das kann ich also nachvollziehen
die öffentlichkeit diskutiert es nicht
die medien nicht die sind auch alle auf
dem trip möglichst viel co2 und für die
po das ist kann daher dass die polen
jetzt nicht die leo zwei kriegen obwohl
sie die neueste version haben will von
denen nur die bundeswehr nach meinem
wissen schon maximal 20 haben müssen wir
nicht erst selbst die haben also alle
dass wetter und diese diskussion muss
geführt werden
auch unter dem aspekt dass zwar der
kanzler zurückhaltend ist ich hab's
schon eben gesagt frau baerbock aber
immer von gewinnen der ukraine rede und
herr merz sich da gestern hingestellt
hat die warum und scholz gefragt hat
warum sagt herr scholz nicht einfach die
ukraine muss diesen krieg gewinnen auch
er hat diesen begriff nun ist es auch
ein matches prinzip so ähnlich wie bei
habeck immer fragen zu stellen die die
beiden noch nicht beantworten dass er
deren stil der rhetorik aber er benutzt
den begriff gewinnen dann muss ich auch
sagen was gewinnen heißt heißt es jetzt
eine rückkehr zu den frontlinien oder
wie heißt das kontakt linien vor dem 24
februar heißt dass ein rückgewinn des
donners und der grimm für die ukraine
oder heißt dass sogar und den russen ein
paar vernichtung im grenzland zu zeigen
nie wieder liebe leute oder heißt es
irgendwo müssen wir eine linie haben und
sie haben es vorhin gesagt henry
kissinger hat das in schonungsloser
offenheit gesagt was mir mehr bedeutet
als das was er sagt sondern dass er
immer noch im weißen haus zu gast ist
das ist natürlich intern die
amerikanische überlegung und ohne die
usa während die ukraine nicht so weit
wie mir ist es auch egal ob ich dann als
putin verstehe oder als ukraine verräter
da stelle ich finde diese politische
debatte ist überfällig unterdrücken
ist es gibt ein bundestagsbeschluss und
da ist klar festgelegt dass es sowas
dass die hilfe so weit geht es ja mal
schon aufgezählt auf welchen ebenen und
auch auf militärische aber dass es
maximal so weit geht dass deutschland
nicht kriegspartei aber dann doch nicht
in ihr haben
bezogen auf die waffen sagen wir mal
einen punkt völlig recht hat diese dass
die leute über waffen seien die selbst
generäle ich bin kein experte geht
ungern über waffen in teilen brauchen
sie die zur selbstverteidigung die
ukraine kann uns alles fordern uns
entscheiden was sie will dass diesen
angriff ist ein souveräner staat wir
müssen entscheiden wie wir der ukraine
am besten helfen können und was
verantwortbar ist es ist nicht
verantwortbar etwas zu tun was in der
klink für immer ein beispiel sagen
carina geringer die affen wenn wir wir
schicken waffen aber die öffentlichkeit
beschimpft uns wir seien im grunde
genommen zögerlich es war ja auch 7 1
dreier von kurzen dann aber das ist eine
frage wie man sagen das ist meine
entscheidung der sache naja ich denke
jeder washington nach paris nach rom
noch london liefert kampf panzer oder
kampfflugzeuge westlicher bauart warum
nicht es gibt diesen ringtausch mit den
panzern sowjetischer macht hat diesen
polen also bestellen sich mal vor dem
deutschen leo das sind keine group.com
keine verletzten bei aus haben wir 50
getöteten sozusagen mit dem deutschen
panzer wir haben das in gang gesetzt die
konsequenzen die sowas haben würde und
deswegen will ja schon sagen wir müssen
ein bisschen immer überlegen was
verantwortbar ist aber irgendwas auch
scheinheiligen oder hole den eindruck zu
erwecken und das wird ja eben sehr
emotionalisiert ihr das team steht das
darf man übrigens auch nicht diesen
angriff ich finde der polin
kriegsverbrecher gehört auch nach
dritten um bereich alles keine frage da
ist die sense nicht aber dieses
ausschließlich denke die militärische
logik und was heißt gewinnen verlieren
ich benutze nur in sachsen oder schon
tut das auch die ukraine nach dem krieg
nicht will die an russland darf ich
nicht gewinnen etwas völlig anderes
die rund 1000 heißt leider zerstört wir
müssen das land wieder vorn wasser hat
das gestern sogar variiert die ukraine
muss bestehen eher weniger als nicht nur
verlieren sie muss eigentlich ein hektar
tieren also ja dann auch gerne doch noch
mal sagen also sie haben völlig recht ja
dass wir die debatte nicht hören und
auch noch nicht ehrlich führen
vielleicht sind wir auch endlich soweit
ja weil wenn sie nämlich um ja ja wir
wie auch immer aber ich war damals ja
und dieses sagen wir müssten über
waffenstillstand räten der italienische
außenminister hatte am 18 im vorschlag
gemacht ja die ärzte gegen den atomkrieg
haben vorschlag gemacht also es gibt
auch die anderen vorschläge ich finde ja
immer sprecher akt ja worüber man redet
wird dann wirklichkeit ich finde wir
reden zu wenig von dem was wir auch der
herr schulenburg ja der ehemalige es ist
ein genie von der nato hat diesen großen
tatsächlich bleibt im cicero gemacht nur
gesagt hat europa hat in dieser rolle
dezidiert die rolle dass wir für den
frieden eintreten aber es liege und es
ist ja auch bei uns hier das territorium
also das ist noch mal was anderes als
die amerikaner was die vielleicht auch
vorhanden das liegt auch ein bisschen
daran glaube ich dass die die
eigentliche opposition gehören
wissenschaftler journalisten diese
teilweise verlassen haben und an den
social media mitmachen nicht nur als
kombattanten r kommen wissenschaftler
und sagen wir jetzt nicht mehr machen
die fertig ist ein lump wir wollen keine
argumente mehr gesehen was fehlt dir
verringern und maschinen über das
schwere waffen das ist auch ein
schwacher mitgemacht habe ich nicht
gemacht habe es war zeit genug sich
einmal etwas historisches seiner den
journalisten auch die in den sozialen
medien dessen posen sind auch meistens
die die im gegensatz zu vielen
politikern vor ort waren und über monate
berichtet haben die natürlich dann auch
eine haltung dazu habe man kriegt
wenn man nicht von mir kriegt nämlich
sehr genau mit was da stattfindet und
das ist ein brutaler krieg ist da gibt
es keine zwei meinungen ich sage nur was
machen sie mit älteren menschen hier
reden jetzt kinder noch rega lebte oder
wenn sie mit denen reden meinen der
generationen die gegen atomrüstung
demonstriert haben und angst vor krieg
gefallen europa kann dann kennen sie
auch mit denen die krieg als social
media wirklichkeit wenn man könnte doch
mal mit der nato man kann nicht mit der
nato wir reden nicht über irak oder
lieber langsam wir reden über die
zweitgrößte atommacht der welt was
russland über uns immer noch ist
deswegen
schon in dieser nukleare eskalation und
twitter soziale hineingeredet haben und
die ersten schon dabei waren von der
kontrollierten eskalation zu sprechen
dass wir das wegen dieses mal
eingekesselt habe ich sage nochmal ich
zumindestens beobachter seit ungefähr
zwei wochen dass ich das alles ein
bisschen eindämmt ich werde übrigens
auch die zurückhaltung von herrn scholz
die ihn jetzt so lange vorgeworfen wurde
als eigentlich tatsache dafür dass unter
der hand schon längst versucht wird wo
ist eigentlich der verhandlungs entwurf
hier wo kommen wir eigentlich sozusagen
raus aus diesem heraus wurden die
verdächtigung strikt ja in wirklichkeit
ist das was die leute wollen uns oder
gegen uns aber im rauschen flächen hilft
halt trotzdem also da habe ich schon
dass es ein dass es ein problem ist dass
er sich sehr lange zurückgehalten hat
und damit nehme ich jetzt nicht position
für das eine oder andere aber muss eine
entscheidung treffen da muss was sagen
die kann auch heißen nein das machen wir
nicht umsonst das juristisch prüfen zum
einen nicht das sagen muss wie eine
verankerung sich
an tiefer werden warum er welche politik
machten haben verstanden warum man nicht
wirklich erklärt warum er
nichts zu gehen der deutsche im schnitt
findet ihr diese nachdenklichkeit eher
gut als dieser wir wissen genau wo wir
hin müssen aber es ist irgendwie
symptomatisch
ich gehe mal davon aus dass auch die
amerikaner sich das ja nicht so leicht
machen wir wenn ich dann höre dass die
wochenlang darüber beraten haben können
wir die mehrfach raketenwerfer liefern
oder ist das nicht doch zu riskant wahl
ist von putin als kriegseintritt
zumindest indirekter art gewertet werden
kann
das hat aber öffentlich lange nicht so
heftig stattgefunden wie wir über jede
haubitze oder über jeden helm
diskutierte man sie so ist populistisch
diese diskussion zu führen denn ich muss
den elisa makro sagt überhaupt nichts
über die frage welche reagieren aber
nicht
und der amerikanische präsident hat um
es interessant dabei sein
verteidigungsminister zurückgepfiffen
der hat nämlich gesagt wir müssen
russland daran hindern sie jemals wieder
stark werden und habe beiden seiten ist
das anders steht aber nee da steht aber
jetzt so auch in dem artikel der new
york times
natürlich bei dem verteidigungsminister
war ja die interpretation dass können
sozusagen ein wechsel des regimes
das haben die amerikaner das geht nie
gut es geht und russland schon gar nicht
insofern war der versprecher aber
tatsächlich natürlich auch schon mal
auffällig
trotzdem ist die debatte weit weniger
heftig und kontrovers in amerika ist ja
selbst sind ja selbst die republikaner
dafür so geht es nicht lieber protein-
und natürlich ist ich bin journalist wie
sie durchaus ja wissen
es hätte ich jetzt eine lösung ich
investiere nur dass wir die debatte
wenigstens führen müssen weil jeder der
hier sitzt weiß ja die
verhandlungslösung ist in weiter ferne
solange putin glaubt er kann sich
leisten überhaupt nicht auf so etwas
einzugehen werden wir was machen sie für
verhandlungen nicht will ich würde
trotzdem noch mal ins feld führen wollen
ob unsere es samt chance also unsere
annahmen da immer so korrekt sind ja
also es gibt einfach auch andere stimmen
die die frage ist zu welchen bedingungen
ist putin bereit zu verhandeln ja also
sooo genau dass ist ein bisschen schade
also das stichwort ist natürlich
neutralität das ist das reizwort ja aber
wenn man das auf den tisch legen würde
ja das eingeständnis machen würde würde
würde das vielleicht auch nicht viel
anderes zu holen ist ja dann ist das
vielleicht anders aus ich will nur sagen
wenn wir die rational sind in diesem
konflikt und immer denken dass der
andere boote in diesem fall irrational
ist ja dann würde ich sagen gibt es
viele andere stimmen die sagen putin hat
wenn ich gut finde ist nicht ihrer zu
nehmen
soll ich das wird wohl
durchdacht strahlt als hätte ich gerade
sagen dass putin nämlich brutal und
aggressiv ist aber durchaus rational und
in ruhe unser design sound machen sollen
putin ist nicht irrational oder es
bestimmt nach der
ja also genau ich möchte heute über die
bundesverfassungsgerichts entscheidung
sprechen meines erachtens also die zu
einem breiten einrichtungs gezogenen im
pflicht ist das eine bankrotterklärung
gewesen und ja also zunächst einmal
abgesehen davon dass die entscheidung
völlig an unserer lebensrealität
vorbeigeht denn wir alle wissen dass
geimpfte und gebürstete sich anstecken
und auch das video ist natürlich weiter
geben aber was mich besonders bewegt und
mir große sorgen bereitet ist der
paradigmenwechsel des
bundesverfassungsgerichts wenn ich
paradigmenwechsel sage dann meine ich
dass das gericht bisher die
vorherrschende denkweise geteilt hat
dass der staat in einer freiheits
einschränkungen vornimmt diese sehr gut
begründen muss davon ist es jetzt aber
komplett abgekehrt was heißt das jetzt
für uns was heißt das für jeden
einzelnen das bedeutet konkret dass der
staat immer dann wenn er vorgibt
menschenleben retten zu wollen in
krisensituationen eben insbesondere
eigentlich alle maßnahmen ergreifen darf
insbesondere auch solche die relativ
offensichtlich untauglich sind oder
nahezu untauglich sind zum beispiel eine
impfpflicht mit einer impfung die nicht
zur ansteckung schützt das heißt das
gericht hat im prinzip im zweifel für
den staat entschieden und sagt immer nur
dann wenn klar widerlegt ist dass eine
annahme nicht zutreffend ist gibt es
sozusagen eine rote linie jetzt ist es
so dass der staat grundsätzlich auch
eine vergangenheit schon eine tendenz
dazu hatte in krisensituationen zum
beispiel bekämpfung raf-terrorismus
unverhältnismäßig in die grundrechte
einzugreifen das ist ein impuls der
vielleicht auch menschlich
nachvollziehbar ist aber gerade dann
brauchen wir eben ein gericht was sagt
stock so geht das nicht weiter wir haben
aber hier gerade das gegenteil davon
erlebt wir haben ein gericht erlebt was
ein quasi ein blankoscheck ausgefüllt
hat und gesagt hat hierfür grundrechts
einschränkungen zum schutz von leben und
so weiter krisensituation ist das jetzt
gibt's keine roten linien ja ich glaube
dass diese entscheidung den rechtsstaat
in einen unerträglichen zustand versetzt
hat die menschen ohnmächtig
zurückgelassen hat und dadurch auch
potenziell den sozialen frieden bedroht
der herbst steht an es werden jetzt
schon wieder corona maßnahmen ins feld
geführt corona pause ist zum negativ
geworden was ich irgendwie auch schon
herr buschmann angeeignet hat
klimaschutz ist ein weiteres großes
thema und ich frage mich wer schützt uns
jetzt eigentlich noch vor dem
übergriffigen staat das
bundesverfassungsgericht ist es nämlich
nicht die frage seid mir direkt mal an
herrn stegner weiter geben ob wir nach
auf unser rechtssystem vertrauen können
und auch keine zunächst medizin habe ich
sehr viel sympathie dafür zu sagen die
bürgerrechte gar nicht dem staat sondern
sie können den bürgern und man darf sie
nur einschränken anders begründet ich
bin aber auch da bei meinem nächsten
pessimistisch wie sie das gleiche
bundesverfassungsgericht hat entschieden
wenn ein flugzeug gekapert wird und
fliegt aus der stadt zu darf der staat
das nicht abschießen
aber dafür wird auch das darf nicht ohne
jedes da darf es nicht tun aber man darf
der kommune 1 nicht vergessen das haben
wir aber schon vergessen dass in der
korona pandemie
wahnsinnig viele menschen einsam und
alleine gestorben sind ja oft haben es
gerade in einer gerade in altenheim urin
kann ein regelung gelten wir uns immer
noch einen allgemeinen stunden oder
werkstätten und anderswo wurde woanders
sich um bürger kümmern müssen mit einer
folge was die wir bei weitem nicht
abgearbeitet haben hat es damals nicht
mehr beerdigungen gegeben außer den
familien selbst den nachbarn den
freunden und denen die als pflegekräfte
teilweise familien ersatzgeschwächt eine
gruselige sache sozusagen die sie nicht
wiederholen darf und wir haben ob man
das gefällt oder nicht in dieser
pandemie gelernt dass da sehr viel mehr
menschen gestorben sind als hätten
sterben müssen wenn wir nach dem der
impfstoff entwickelt worden ist eine
höhere quote gehabt hätten denn diese
impfung schützt zwar nicht vor ansteckt
jahre aber wahr das hab ich denn das
haben wir den satz zu ende führen bitte
ich denke schützt schon davor
lebensbedrohlich zu erkranken das davor
schützen ja diejenigen die davon auch
sowie tot aber das ist hier halt niemand
dass der staat sich kümmern das ist so
eine die gesundheit zu erhalten recht
auf leben zu sichern das verstehe ich
schon es darf nicht so weit gehen dass
bürgerliche freiheiten eingeschränkt
werden über das maß hinaus was in all
das ist noch genau wenn ich das sagen
darf oder bzw also als frage an frau
hart weil ich es tatsächlich nicht weiß
aber ich habe diesen satz in erinnerung
ich habe mir das urteil auch an geguckt
wo sich das bundesverfassungsgericht in
einem der zentralen absätze ich
eigentlich darauf beruft dass die
fachgesellschaften in diesem saal waren
gemeint das paul-ehrlich-institut usw
angeraten hätten und so weiter weil die
fachgesellschaften das jetzt so sagen
darum kann das bundesverfassungsgericht
sagen ich schränke die grundrechte genau
jetzt mache ich mal ein beispiel ja also
sein beispiel ja also demnächst habe ich
ein paar demografen diese demografen
stellen fest wir haben zu wenig kinder
ja wir brauchen wieder drei kinder pro
frau sodann kam diese fachgesellschaft
demographie geht zum
bundesverfassungsgericht und sagt das
recht mein bauch gehört mir wofür wir
mal gestritten haben in den 1970 er
jahre dieses recht ist jetzt mal so zu
sagen weil die fachgesellschaften das
anders sehen werden diese rechte
abgeräumt ist das ist ein sehr
technokratisch ist verständnis was ich
hier gezeigt hat wobei man hat es
runtergebrochen auf die regierung darf
so zu sagen hat natürlich einen gewissen
einschätzungsspielraum auch völlig
zurecht allerdings wurde der hier
eindeutig überstrapaziert denn was auch
die fachgesellschaften nicht gesagt
haben hier ging es ja in der
entscheidung ging es vor allem um
fremdschutz ich möchte auch noch mal auf
ihren stegner eingehen weil sie das
beispiel mit dem luftsicherheitsgesetz
angesprochen habe selbst wenn wir sagen
okay von mir aus diesen ganz weiden
einschätzungsspielraum und die
fachgesellschaften haben zumindest
gesagt na ja irgendwie im wirkung 41
kommend was prozent was erschreckend ist
wenn man sich jetzt mal überlegt das ist
nur um fremdschutz ging aber die
ureigenen verfassungsrechtlichen fragen
nämlich darf ich menschenleben gegen
menschenleben abwägen wie damals in der
luftsicherheitsgesetz entscheidung nehme
ich es ist ja ganz klar dass durch die
impfung stadt darüber können wir zu
schreiben in welchem ausmaß aber die
führt eben in einigen fällen dazu dass
menschen sehr schwer erkranken gesunde
menschen sehr schwer erkranken oder
sterben das heißt ich opfere faktisch
einen teil der aber ich hoffe faktisch
menschen nehmen um andere zu retten
warum hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
regelt lediglich einsatz dazu gesagt im
sinne von na ja aber es ist so so selten
und man rettet so sehr viele ohne auf
diese ureigene frage die die
menschenwürde berührt einzugehen und das
ist ein absolutes total versagen selbst
einmal alles andere sagen würde okay
geht noch wenn ich dann fertig 2
anmerkung dazu erstens sind wir wieder
in unserem punkt dass es dinge gibt die
so nicht vermitteln können sie werden
der mehrzahl und das ist sind zwei
drittel die sich haben impfen lassen sie
vermitteln können dass es ein ausdruck
von freiheit sei dass ungeimpfte
jederzeit rumlaufen können andere
anstecken und zwar leichter als die
geimpften und sich auch selbst gefährde
wieso denn nicht
in meinen augen wo die freiheit das ist
auch eine freiheit von
bin gesinnungs liberale aber da teile
ich die haltung der
viele leute daran gestorben das können
sie nicht vergessen wir haben ja das
erste mal dass wir sprechen dann ist
aber geschichte in den boden gelegt dass
ganz viele menschen gestorben sind die
länger hätten leben können
im moment sind sie in die pflicht die
leute hoffen und war selber sonst
gegeben hatte ziege dass leute sehen das
ist
freiheit sich den weg zu holen ist
deutlich geringer als der eingriffe
nicht dass ich mein leben beenden weil
entweder mich jemand anstecke ja was
denn da hab ich auf den
intensivstationen die situation habe man
dagegen dass wir wissen dass wir uns
beide weiter das inhaltlich was wir
richten jetzt deutlich mehr als nicht
geben aber wir müssen auch mal ins
verhältnis das ganze setzen ja klar ist
jeder der stirbt ist einer zu viel
einsatz den sie in einer freiheitlichen
demokratie einfach so nicht sagen so
sterben musst du ja straßenverkehr dem
ja auch nicht haben oder also haben wir
das wird nicht gebraucht und jetzt
fangen über impfen generell
das wollte was ich sagen wollte mich
wundert ihre einlassung dieses urteil
sie kritisieren das ist natürlich
konsequent dass in die entscheidende
weichenstellung war ein anderes urteil
des verfassungsrechtlich als sie die
verfassungsklage der fdp geschmettert
haben da steht alles drin und das ist
von einem zionismus ich meine grundes
notbremse da steht da drin alle
einzelmaßnahmen hoch bedenklich gaal
eigentlich geht das gar nicht aber in
gänze hat der staat doch diesen hempel
eine lenkung und gehört heute ihn und
ich bin eigentlich ganz froh dass du
deinen letzten thema keine einigung
hatten verdacht für eine freie
debattenkultur schönen abend noch bis
nächste woche dienstag tschüss
[Musik]